I did today our research conference is
consisting of a journal club that one of
our clinical informatics fellows dr.
Amelia grace will present dr. grace is a
is in the clinical informatics physician
subspecialty fellowship she is a
physician by training went to
undergraduate at Stanford and medical
school at Washington University in st.
Louis did a residency in pediatrics and
pediatric neurology at st. Louis
Children's Hospital and then we were
fortunate enough to have her join our
fellowship program and so this will be a
journal club presentation maybe I'll let
her describe how she's going to run this
session and we'll go from there thank
you very much so yeah well today we'll
be discussing psychosocial information
used for clinical positions in diabetes
care I'd like to keep things pretty
informal so I feel like discussions are
generally better when they happen when
you think of a point so please feel free
to just raise your hand and we can talk
about something on a slide that's
confusing or that you object to or that
you'd like to put some perspective on
and so we can just yeah don't be shy
that discussion happened where it may
so just for some background psychosocial
and information it gave social
determinants of health is basically
anything that clinician should have or
has to identify don't where patients
might have issues in terms of adhering
to a care plan accessing care accessing
medications etc so the things that the
physicians usually find that annoys them
are the lack of self care behavior so we
usually have those frustrations in terms
of oh they're not eating right they're
not showing up to get their labs drawn
and they can never come to clinic all of
those things so the framework that this
paper is using is looking at that as a
combination of both personal factors and
environmental factors and then assessing
how different clinicians approach those
in their decision-making and practice
so social determinants have been
recognized for a while as a useful and
important component of clinical care so
they have been rudimentary included in
the HR but there's still a long way to
go as far as how standardized they
should be so there is some movement
towards getting those put in as link
codes or no were there yet and as far as
how to manage those reporting and how to
incorporate community service referrals
are still very much kind of a new new
field and part of what this paper is
trying to look at is how do physicians
actually use this data so how should we
support those workflows so we don't
really know how we should incorporate
some of that information so if someone
has housing insecurity or food
insecurity etc should that show up to
the clinician is some sort of summary of
you should that guide any additional
prompts for resources do different
members of the care team say social
worker a clinician nurse practitioner
etc need different information or would
they make different decisions based on
the same information and you know who's
gonna step on whose toes and then if
also kind of unclear one what physicians
are actually doing with the social
determinants of health information and
to what they should do so this is
looking more at what they are doing in
the current state so for their model
issue here they chose type 2 diabetes
which is a pretty good model for social
determinance of health evaluation for
one thing it's extremely common and also
has a very strong correlation and it's
clinical outcomes with a race in
education level and then some other
issues as far as physiologically that
make it so important to interact with
the social determinants of health and
probably why those correlations are so
strong for one thing you have to have
regular monitoring so if there's an
issue with affording labs getting
transportation having a regular phone
number all of those types of things can
interfere with that
refrigeration can be a huge issue if you
have housing insecurity or your
electricity is getting turned off yeah
we don't all of this based on your
expected habits with your carbs and if
you don't have a staple source of food
it's kind of difficult to maintain how
many carbs you're getting at any given
time and so we see generally a lot of
long-term sequelae you know diabetic
retinopathy vascular disease peripheral
neuropathies coming from long-term under
management of diabetes and high
hemoglobin a1cs which will kill you but
unfortunately if you try and control
people too tightly and they don't have a
social situation where that is something
that they can do safely they don't have
family members that would notice if
they're acting a little loopy if their
sugar is low if they don't have them
stable enough source of food so if you
keep their blood sugar low and they're
getting hypoglycemic they don't have
access to a candy bar or an orange or
whatever to boost them back up so if you
try to over shooter you try to treat
someone who doesn't have a stable living
situation as though they do you can
bottom the mountain kill them so this
was a mixed-methods evaluation i'm
started off with a qualitative portion
and then kind of codified that into a
quantitative portion as well so it
started out with semi-structured
interviews they took 17 clinicians they
tried to get a kind of a broad look at
you know how often should these people
have been practicing in a variety of
locations and just said if you tend to
deal with type 2 diabetes in the
outpatient setting and if your practice
includes economically marginalized
people you know we'd like to talk to you
and then they started with three
physicians who were close to the
investigators and then kind of proceeded
in a Snowbowl manner with 14 additional
physicians from their practices and then
once they kind of decided they had
reached saturation with a classic
qualitative approach you know we're
getting all of the same information over
and over again so they decided it's time
to move forward and go to the
quantitative so from those themes they
used a grounded Theory approach so they
looked at what the transcripts of the
interviews were saying devised some
themes does
devised some codes for those themes and
then kind of coalesced some of those
themes into a few larger higher-level
themes they look to add a quarter of the
responses and had another Raider go
through them for interrater reliability
they found a 98 point a 98 percent
agreement so that's pretty good so I
they felt like what they're coding makes
some good sense and then they also point
out they did some cognitive interviews
which they didn't clarify that much in
the paper when they had written their
survey questions based on the
information they'd gotten from their
surveys they then did some in-depth
interviews to see whether or not those
survey questions made good sense to
people
apparently the cognitive interviewing
technique is most common in forensic
interviews which doesn't seem
particularly appropriate but what they
are able to do is basically guide people
through and ask more probing questions
as far as what their thought process was
on reading the interview questions that
they had devised and from there the
clinicians were able to say well at this
point I think it would be helpful if you
asked about a medication change or
adding brand name versus generic etc so
that they kind of refined their surveys
before that went out to the whole group
and then for the quantitative portion of
their study they did an online survey
they looked at a number of different
providers so they had MDS nurse
practitioners and then diabetes
educators who consisted of both
registered nurses and registered
dieticians and the way they got these is
that they had some access to various
listservs that they basically said hey
here's here's the survey please please
answer it their participation rates
we're actually pretty good as you can
see from the percentages sorry that's
crazy crazy small um but they got about
you know 19 percent response rates for
the nurse practitioners 30 percent for
the educators which in surveillant is
very very promising
pretty even split between gender and
then most of their interview
participants were fairly young over half
of them had less than 10 years of
experience
and then if you were older and then in
the final survey responses they had
about a third 10 years 3rd 11 to 20 and
then a third of over 20 years of the
docks they had family medicine internal
medicine endocrinology and as the most
commonly represented and they had a few
endocrine emergency medicine but those
people are either less likely to be
seeing at risk populations because more
wealthy people can afford specialists or
if you're a hospitalist and so on you
don't necessarily see people in the
outpatient setting which is what they
were looking at here so the fats that
they use for the quantitative portion
they looked at a one-way ANOVA between
differences of clinician types so they
had their groups are you an MD are you a
nurse practitioner
are you a diabetes educator and that
will show whether the whole group is
significant and then they had two keys
honest significant difference post hoc
test which in their paper they called
honestly which basically looks at if you
have an anova that says the whole
difference between groups is significant
and mass the two keys test is designed
to say well which of those groups are
the ones that are actually driving those
differences so it basically goes through
a bunch of pairwise comparisons so
physician versus nurse practitioner or a
nurse practitioner versus a diabetes
educator physician versus diabetes
educator and sees whether those are
significant and then they did a
bonferroni for multiple comparisons
Corrections so the results for the
interviews they basically looked at
which things clinicians were looking at
in terms of how they wanted to assess
what patients could manage the big
themes was was the patient able to
manage their own personal life finances
getting to appointments and so on were
there environmental issues housing
insecurity difficulties with
transportation etc did they understand
their treatment were they able to access
and afford treatment were there any
other barriers to self-care and like
including mental health and then a lot
of physicians especially in the more
at-risk practice settings talked a lot
about kind of being mindful of the
reasons for non-compliance or not
adherence
and then for the group that were
community health clinic providers there
was a those that group was much more
likely to consider it a matter of course
that they're finishing the interview
should always take into account social
determinants of health and that they
would incorporate that regardless of any
red flags that's probably some kind of
rudimentary you know Bayesian intuition
that you know the baseline probability
of people in these clinics needing extra
resources is so high that those
providers have adapted to getting into
that workflow that you just always have
to ask in other settings providers were
less likely to say oh I always look for
social determinants of health so they
would consider you know if a patient
wasn't well controlled on their diabetes
then they would say well now I have to
look at well it might be going wrong if
they knew of any social determinants of
health complications they would ask
about them in their follow-ups and if
they had any additional comorbidities
especially mental health concerns
whether or not mental health gets
classified as a medical comorbidity or
social determinants of health can be
very controversial and can differ across
you know what the paradigm is for any
given study so it's kind of worth
keeping in mind how that is classified
and then any life changes so for
instance if someone gets divorced gets
loses their home or anything like that
loses a job has to move those can
dramatically change their ability to
keep up with their diabetes care and so
clinicians endorse that they are mindful
of those things but not all of them had
an opera or II look to say we're going
to screen for those proactively so most
providers said if we're doing a new
diagnosis of diabetes that is usually a
trigger point for discussing social
social determinants of health kind of
counseled that patient through how their
ongoing medical management is going to
change and become a lot more intensive
over the course of that care and then
kind of the big things that providers
had to think about and decide were you
know do they think patients can manage
an insulin regimen and that mean
like can they manage it cognitively do
they have access to her refrigerator do
they have access to a regular supply of
food is that going to change can a
patient afford insulin and which
insulins can they afford so there was a
recurring theme of being just using the
very generic two-hour insulin as opposed
to some of the more novel analogues that
can be short acting and long-acting and
combined which would probably get better
a1c control but a lot of those patients
couldn't afford that so they had to
decide you know what what can we offer
that will be feasible and then in terms
of what they would decide the target
glucose for that patient should be some
patients needed to be more permissive
because they were going to have such
variability in that target similarly to
the a1c also patients would describe
well if I'm feeling really down or tired
or I feel out of it and I can't work if
my sugar is too low etc that would
affect kind of how they were able to
practically manage that plan and there
was a lot of discussion of you know
needing to support the patient in
perhaps a less mathematically medically
perfect glucose and hemoglobin a1c
management in favor of coming up with a
plan that they could feel invested in
and actually contribute to and cooperate
with and then the other question is you
know if we devised up a really
complicated treatment plan is this
patient going to be able to understand
the instructions and additionally carry
out those instructions
the other big prompt for social
determinants of health was if the
patient needed a referral to psychiatry
or to any other social services
community groups food banks etc so then
based on that they set up a quantitative
survey from there they got six different
modalities of social determinants of
health that they looked at so those were
financial strain mental health status
life stressors food security health
literacy and social support and what
they were looking at the leftmost bar in
each of these is the total followed by
physicians nurse practitioners and then
diabetes educators at the far right of
each cluster so you can see over all the
physicians tended to be the least
engaged with how much they were asking
about social determinants of health
these are done on a six point Likert
scale you can actually a five-point
Likert scale but six is just hanging out
up there but you can see most people
tended to understand financial strain is
a pretty common thing to ask about food
security was the least engaged with from
the physicians which does kind of make
me worry since this is a disease process
that is so intimately tied with what you
eat and when and how often
fortunately the dietitians educators
were pretty good at asking about food
security so that's somewhat reassuring
but you can see across the board that
the physicians tended to be less engaged
although they were still endorsing like
a four on the five point qualitative
skills they were still relatively
engaged but just not as much as
ancillary staff this is a reworking of
Table three because I objected to how
they provided it in the paper so what
they looked at is would providers ask
about social determinants of health in
all circumstances when there were
chronic issues and when there were new
circumstances and when those
circumstances changed what they had
initially reported was you know of those
who had asked patients about their
multiple chronic condition what
percentage were primary care providers
versus nurse practitioners versus
diabetes educators which I did not find
made intuitive census terms of what the
frequency and how those care providers
responded so what I've done instead is
looked at of the total number of primary
care providers nurse practitioners and
educators how many of them asked these
questions and in what circumstances so
you can see overall the uptake is pretty
good
81 percent of physicians eighty-seven
percent of nurse practitioners and 84
percent of diabetes educators would ask
about social determinants of health in
all circumstances as a caveat of course
this is a pretty enriched population for
physicians who are going to be aware of
these kind of issues
just because part of the inclusion
criteria was that they were aware that
they were treating
patients who were more likely to have
obstacles and they're the people who
would care enough to join in to this
survey so I'm sure if you asked to
garden-variety unsampled a primary care
physician group with a different
socio-economic balance you probably
wouldn't get 81% and then from there
they were also looking at those who
would ask about those issues in chronic
or new circumstances I did have some
questions in terms of how they
calculated this out because the in all
circumstances and chronic circumstances
is greater than a hundred percent when
you add them up and even just one of
them for instance all circumstances plus
patients with multiple chronic
conditions which means that obviously
the percentage can't only be those who
didn't ask in multiple chronic
conditions but logically if it should be
additive and you're as some of them are
asking in all circumstances you either
have to have a number that is less than
or equal to 100% minus eighty one or you
have to have a number that is greater
greater than eighty one percent
depending on how you are setting up here
a questionnaire and how that logic is
going through so I think that the way
that B stats are falling out indicate
that some providers are saying I ask in
all circumstances and they either didn't
ask or they didn't answer the follow-up
survey questions or they interpreted
that as asking especially or taking
extra care pres other providers seemed
to answer both the all circumstances and
some circumstances because that's the
only way that I can get the math to work
out unless anyone disagrees with me but
you can see some of the common issues
that they're seeing our patients who are
very complicated who have poor adherents
who have either diagnosed or undiagnosed
mental health issues I wonder about the
primary care physicians because I'm
fortunate that's a relatively low number
but if you think someone has a diagnosed
undiagnosed mental health condition
you're their primary care provider I
would hope you'd make some efforts
towards getting them diagnosed but that
doesn't always happen
I just flat-out don't like this table
yes Oh lovely his comment is in the
methods they use a sampling strategy is
initially networking and then maximum
variations sampling and so he says that
maximum variation sampling is a method
that researchers use that's what's
usually a burst a small number of units
or cases that Maxima is a diversity
relevant to the research question and
commonly used in clinical informatics
thank you all right so here we have
basically every possible variation of
medical decision making all graded on a
four-point Likert scale and apparently
it's crucially important that we have
standard deviations on every single line
because I think that really adds to be
understanding whether you agree so the
four broad terms that we're looking at
and this is please don't read this this
is only here for me to complain that I
just don't like the visualization but
the main issues in terms of what medical
decisions will be made based on the
information from the social determinants
of health or what the target level of
control is so where do you want that
patient to be aiming with their glucose
their hemoglobin a1c do you make any
recommendations such as for dietary
physical activity additional caregiver
support follow-up times etc how you
select medications whether they are
orals insulins whether they're brand
name or not etc and then whether or not
you make referrals for instance to
specifically diabetes based management
or additional community support services
other specialty care so again this is on
a Likert scale so never kind of
sometimes mostly always you can see that
overall people are pretty much ceiling
there's a general preponderance of high
3s and low fourth throughout all of
these so that shows that people are
overall have engaging with this issue
and they perceive for himself report
that they're doing that rather
frequently that said I would wonder
whether or not this Likert scale is
capturing as enough granularity in terms
of what people are answer
ringg to justify this level of drill
down for the topics when your outcome
measure is admittedly fairly crude so
the only ones that they endorsed as
being statistically significant were if
you would make physical activity
recommendations again they did do a
bonferroni which is fairly conservative
in terms of how it restricts for
multiple comparisons and overall you can
see that the diabetes educators endorsed
being relatively more likely to make
decisions and changes in their decision
plans with patients based on social
determinants and the physicians tend to
be the least likely I think some graphs
and scatter plots would be helpful here
but I didn't bother to make one myself I
apologize and I think it'll be
interesting to see kind of what those
decisions could be across those various
ancillary services and how they would
approach those so for our discussion
this was the view that they looked at in
terms of what the decision process was
most providers and this is mostly from
the interview portion although the
quantitative did bear it out but this is
kind of over enriched for the MD
perspective they looked at you know is
the patient doing well clinically and
then if the patient if the provider
thought that they should always ask for
psycho social determinants of health
they would then proceed to ask about
them and then use that in their care
planning and then if the patient wasn't
doing well clinically the things that
people tended to look at for what could
be the cause of either poor adherence or
poor numbers or additional sequelae of
disease progression would be you know if
there's something chronically going on
that's been an issue for this patient
for a long time is there a new
circumstance either related to the
novelty of the diabetes diagnosis or is
the patient themselves new to that
provider or has there been a change in
that patient circumstances as far as
their outcomes have changed abruptly
they have suddenly stopped caring for
themselves as well as they should
which would prompt you know
has this person develops and
unrecognised depression have they lost
access to either their material or
social resources etc and then once that
is incorporated this this model is very
charitable that it doesn't include oh I
asked about it and I found no no way to
incorporate it so it assumes that
everything gathered here has been used
constructively which i think is very
optimistic so my conclusions that they
drew with it are ends and registered
dieticians were the most likely to
consider psychosocial factors and
providers across all three groups were
more likely to be able to take into
account individual level social
determinants of health compared to
community indicators and the author's
pointed out that there is a bit of a
disconnect because EHR data tends to be
pretty good at pulling in community
level social determinants because you
know they have a zip codes and they can
pull that kind of information
automatically and there have been some
attempts at piloting you know community
vital sign type score something that
will look at the patients for instance
zip code and say well here are some of
their baseline risks relative to what
demographic information is already in
the chart the trouble is that most
providers didn't seem to find that as
useful as you know are you married did
you lose your job you have stable
housing etc obviously some of those
demographic factors can raise your
probability of having individual factors
affect you but in terms of what the
provider thought they could do is their
next step with the community level
factors they seem to have a you know not
my Lane kind of attitude and then again
most of the providers of MDS nurses and
nurse practitioners and educators did
endorse as their common practice that
they would always consider social
determinants of health and again the
strongest predictor of that was what
practice setting they had and thus what
patient population they were more likely
to see so some limitations that I was
looking at one I found it a little odd
that the qualitative portion
was only looking at MDS and then set the
quantitative portion to look at multiple
different providers I would actually
really like to see what were the results
of qualitative interviews with the nurse
practitioners and with the dieticians
because I think they would have a lot of
richness in that perspective so you're
basically establishing what your
quantitative survey paradigm will be
based on the experience of the
clinicians who happen to be the ones who
are least likely to actually ask about
social determinants of health and then
you're trying to map the practice
patterns of people in other services to
those decisions that are determined you
know by someone else's workflow so I
found that to be a little bit odd and I
would have liked to have seen perhaps
one study that went hears theme
generation physicians and then here will
survey physicians here are themes from
the nurse practitioners or to get themes
from all from you know separate three
groups and then see if there was any way
that they would want to compare and
contrast those in a structured interview
but I think they did lose out on some
opportunities from limiting what they
were going to be investigating based on
who their initial population was for
their qualitative portion I also found
it interesting that they had different
heralds from different states I think
that's just because when they had access
to listserv that we're able to get them
oh here a lot of diabetes educators that
we can contact at once here are a lot of
nurse practitioners that we can contact
it at once and those listservs for
state-based but I do kind of wonder if
we're perhaps getting any noise from the
different settings that those people are
working in either are there differences
in education in those states are there
differences in the culture of those
offices if you asked all MDS nurse
practitioners and dietitians in one
clinic or set of clinics in one
community would you get a different
answer and also are there differences in
terms of what practices at the top of
your license means in those different
states so does that affect what medical
decision making a registered dietitian
is making if they're in Michigan versus
Texas versus Maryland and so just
because of how they sampled that that
kind of introduced
some complex complexity to their answers
that we don't know and again I wonder
how sensitive electorate scales are
because pretty much everyone was
answering on the four to five level I
mean there were a couple of threes but
you'd kind of have to wonder are you
basically getting a binary outcome
between mostly and always and is that
the best way to approach some of this
data and then like we talked about with
the survey inconsistencies you know some
people were answering yes I always asked
about this and then I also asked if
there's been a change in their
circumstances or if there's a new
patient some people seem to answer I
always ask about this and leave the rest
either blank or no so there I think
there would be some opportunity for data
cleanup for exploration in terms of how
people were interpreting those questions
because there's no single answering
behavior that would explain this just
statistics that they have and then I
would really be interested in terms of
if your dietitian says well here's how I
would change their diabetes plan based
on their social determinants of health
and the MD isn't asking presumably the
person also has an MD involved in their
care if those two treatment
recommendations differ does that go to
the MD going oh you know I'm only have
ten minutes to see this patient if you
say they're not going to be able to make
this sure we'll do what you say or is it
no I'm the MD and I say he needs to be
on this level of insulin like how do
those mismatches get accounted for and
how do those manifest in the ultimate
care plans so other things that could be
investigated on the same paradigm like
we talked about having additional care
providers participate in the theme
generation I think the broad in the
scope of what we're looking at and then
I think the amount of what they looked
at for their sample size was appropriate
but with any of these different
parameters we can mix and match them if
we had more people to study for any
given group so wouldn't differ by years
of experience for people who perhaps had
a more modern paradigm of medical
education more tuned to social
determinants of health or would the
grizzled folks who have been in the
trenches and have learned the hard way
more likely to it to pay attention to
social determinants
then kind of how do how does the social
determinants of health asking because we
have here are the things they asked
about we have here are the contexts in
which they ask but there wasn't the
ability to kind of check for an
interaction between those two things so
if you're someone who always asks and
then you notice a problem do you drill
deeper what sort of things do you drill
deeper into if you are asking about
social determinants of health because
there's a change in clinical status or
you've been made aware that there's a
change in a personal situation for that
patient does that guide you know the
depth and breadth of what you're looking
at and how actionable it is and then
which of these domains would actually
correspond to better diabetes outcomes
is there about is one of these more
predictive than the other and then kind
of beyond so those are thought things
that I thought could be addressed from a
similar study design just more patient
some slight restructuring of kind of
going more in depth of what they were
already looking at and this would be
kind of the next step beyond that is
what could we look at in terms of how to
optimize what is available within the
EHR and how should that be done to
affect social determinants of health
capture and utilization so multiple
enterprise EHRs have tried to have some
form of social determinants screening
questionnaires or other tools is there
any evaluation and analysis that we can
do that could determine you know
superiority or non inferiority of any of
those modalities and then if you're
going to base any clinical decision
support on the social determinants are
you going to get pushback from
clinicians what is the right point in
the workflow to work on that what kind
of alert or other notification or
display is going to get your best uptake
if we incorporate some of that decision
support is that actually going to
translate into better outcomes and then
what about prompting a more proactive
screening so there were a number of
clinicians that said oh we assume that
they've everyone's kind of got their
lives together until they seem to follow
through the cracks until they have a
poor outcome
and then we look into it whereas other
physicians kind of had that philosophy
of we should always ask from the
beginning and check all the people who
are always asking more proactive at
catching those issues and is that
translating it's a better clinical
outcomes or is that just too noisy a
system that we can't tell so we don't
know yet
next is once we have theoretical
framework in terms of the social
determinants behavior the EHR
behavior how could we implement that
clinically so is that something that the
physician is going to ask face-to-face
should that be supported in any type of
you know workflow artifact like their
smart set or their visit navigator how
should that be recorded is what levels
of standardization should we have or
social social determinants capture you
know there are some things that are you
know are you homeless are you not that
could be binary or you know how stable
is your housing situation are you on a
friend's couch are you on the street are
you on a shelter are you in a shelter
are you somewhat food insecure you like
there's so many different ways that you
could mathematically conceptualize that
problem even assuming you want to
structure data and then there's also a
situation where there's a lot of value
and narrative data and how should we
incorporate that into our EHRs and in
what contexts and for whom who wants to
see this data and when a big issue with
people who really try to incorporate
this data into their clinical workflows
is how do we establish the currency of
this data there can be some provider
pushback or some patient pushback if
they come to clinic and every time
they're there they have to kind of go
through all of the things that are very
stressful in their lives sometimes they
can be very resistant to that and
they're like you know you know I've got
these hardships can we move on
but then there's well they were homeless
last month
are they still homeless they were
homeless a year ago what what do we
determine as you know copy forwardable
data versus how often should we
reestablish the validity of that data
then you know social determinants of
health have social consequences being
social so are there any addition
privacy measures that we have to take
for any of these and is there any like
break glass status that we need to think
of is implementing any of those
safeguards going to reduce uptake of the
utility of how that information might
actually help their clinical planning
and who decides that and whether or not
clinicians can have a closed-loop
paradigm of okay I sent this person out
for a referral to a Food Bank to a
behavioral health center in their
neighborhood etc that often doesn't come
back to the EHR very well I don't know
if that was able to remote in but not if
you're here text Brian because working
on a number of getting that information
back to the providers in his clinic and
so he would have some insight in terms
of via the complexity of that problem
and actually allowing that follow-up
next up we do have some ethical
considerations so if you are deciding
that you know we'd want a predictive
model for social determinants for
instance for diabetes care how should we
incorporate that into the EHR is that
something that the provider would find
welcomed or frustrating is that
something that would create good
anticipatory guidance for a more
feasible plan of care or would it kind
of shunt people who are already systemic
ly marginalized into you know a more
fatalistic well there's no point in
prescribing insulin for you anyway kind
of mentality so is that going to prompt
more thorough discussion and better
allied decision-making or is that going
to close off potential avenues of care
and how should we do that
thoughtfully the next question I would
have for some of the answers we got in
the structured interview for this paper
is a lot of physicians for describing
things like oh this person's social
situation is such that I I wouldn't feel
safe having them on a very tight glucose
control I don't think they'd be able to
manage it I'd be worried if I put this
personal an insulin they'd overdose and
and die because they couldn't manage it
or whatever else so I think there's some
very important ethical considerations in
terms of how much therapy therapeutic
alliance should you have with that
should you tell a patient
here if we're gonna say your hemoglobin
a1c is gonna be like nine or 12 you know
you're gonna be the long-term risks of
that here's the risk of if we type
control you really tightly what
resources do you have like or is it
feasible for you to make these changes
in your life to have regular access to a
refrigerator could you or should you
move in with a family member like those
are pretty heavy conversations and we
know that whenever patients are provided
with something that has a you know the
correct thing to do would be this people
will often try to please the person who
is interviewing them and say oh yeah I
could do this or I could try to do that
and possibly you know commit to more
than is feasible but on the flip side of
that if the provider is making that
assessment for themselves that oh this
plan wouldn't be feasible for that
patient that person might not have the
ability to mobilize resources that they
may have or may put a priority on if
they understood the true risks of that
similarly if the patient says well I
feel really crummy when my sugar is low
and I don't feel like I can take care of
my kids or go to work you know how much
education and awareness is there of the
long-term sequelae of that and how how
thoughtful is that shared
decision-making do we have we can have
the best predictive model for you know
this person is unlikely to be able to
afford this insulin
what can providers do what should
providers do what should communities
nonprofits etcetera be doing to say well
this person needs access to long-acting
or extremely short term insulin is that
being effectively leveraged in some way
and are these tools encouraging that
better utilization of resources and
seeking out of better resources or is it
shunting people into second tier care
there's something I should think of
should you require a referral to
additional social services if you're
saying your term for target hemoglobin
a1c is nine is that considered an
appropriate management plan without
requiring some sort of at least
evaluation of remediation for those
issues that are putting that patient
into that situation
I'll open it up for questions in the
comments hi I mean a thanks that was a
great talk um I'm just interested in if
you were to look at whether the degree
of engagement with social determinants
of health kind of like how that
correlates with actual patient outcome
with studying that be complicated by the
fact that providers who might be more
engaged with social determinants of
health might be taking care of patients
who have more complicated or severe
cases so you kind of have to like tease
apart those two relationships yeah you
basically have to have some means of a
provider independent way of determining
what the social determinants of health
are because if you are saying oh this
person has a lot of really bad
predictors and that's all if your if
your catchment is all view of what the
provider is documenting you're not
necessarily catching people who are
worse off you might be catching better
providers who are asking for that
similarly some providers might be more
likely to ask and then document for
people who less obviously or who more
obviously don't have their lives
together
so someone if people are taking a kind
of a red flag approach and you know
there are some people in some
communities or if you go to the doctor
you wear your best clothes you make sure
that all of your kids are you know hair
and ribbons in the whole bit so that
they're very reserved as far as not
showing any level of vulnerability so
those people might be much more likely
to skip through the cracks depending on
what the provider behavior is so you'd
have to figure out you know what is your
base truth and who decides and how do
you catch that and then how do you deal
with a Hawthorne effect for going
through and assessing that what is known
to the provider verse which is what is
the providers workflow how well are they
documenting what they know and then what
actions are the provider is taking
specifically based on that information
and assuming you can capture all of
those things you'd have to pretty
complicated statistical model to
it'll out some I've read people
asserting that that actually the health
care system is not a good place to
collect social determinants of health
that you know there are eyes and ears
out in the community and to hear some
people describe it some of the big
problems are actually getting that in to
the records so that when it is time for
social determinants of health to
influence clinical decision making that
that information be available their
decision support you've described I'm
just wondering if you could comment on
how that kind of fits into what was
looked at in this study so I think from
the methodology of this study they were
very much looking at what the providers
are trying to seek out and what they
value when when and why which i think is
a slightly different question than what
you're asking for you know what else is
known and how else can we get social
determinants of health the background
that might be withheld or unavailable
from providers based on community
knowledge I think there are some good
points to that there are some people who
have a lot of very understandable
distrust of the medical system and that
is going to affect their willingness to
engage in care the amount of information
we'll provide and their trust and the
decisions made based on that information
there's also a lot of problems with
looking at eyes and ears out in the
community there can be people who
significantly disagree about what other
people's risk factors are certainly in
Pediatrics we've had our fair share of
one parent will swear that the other
person has this or that issue and that
can be very contentious and finding out
whether or not that's an actual drug
problem or you know parent who doesn't
like the custody arrangement and all
sorts of other things so yeah I guess I
mean I guess I'm thinking about you know
people who get services out in the
community you know I chatting I was
chatting a few weeks ago with someone
who works for Moda health you know our
insurance company and who's very
interested in social determinants of
health and you know notes that you know
for examples there are services like
meals on wheels that go out into these
communities and actually gather data
well or well or they deliver services
but they're in a position to gather data
like you know oh I delivered a meal into
this person's house and you know it's
it's a mess or you know it's the middle
of summer and they have no air
conditioner you know things things like
that that that's you know as opposed to
you know a physician trying to collect
that information during a 15 minute
office visit I I'm just I think I am
actually asking I'm I think maybe a way
to put it with regards to this paper is
actually whether this paper is asking
the right question I mean I suppose it's
important for clinicians to to know you
know to look at ways that you can
incorporate social determinants of
health but you know it may be a real
question is you know when is the right
time to do it and in those situations
how do you how do you actually do it
yeah so there would be a lot of
potential applications for some sort of
you know summary display or dashboard
type view or you know patient summary of
you know if they've gotten meal
assistance that should show up for if
they have you know rent control or you
know an apartment building has been
condemned can that get reported to
anyone who lives in that zip code like
full extended zip code kind of thing
plausible um I would be interested to
know what the privacy policy is and what
the consents are for all of those
different service providers so for
instance if it's like a mental health
clinic they would have very strict lock
downs on what they can disclose and
saying you know would you like us to
provide this information your primary
health care provider may be welcome in
some circumstances but you know if
you're in an abusive situation and your
spouse has the same primary care
provider as you do
there's so many different components so
in the general perspective of having a
more holistic data gathering for social
determinants and having that be
available for clinician review as
opposed to requiring a paradigm that
asks about these things I think is a
very good very good point it would just
be really something else to make it work
so I kind of um I had some questions
along the same lines of bills I guess
which are or maybe some comments too
which is like having worked for a lot of
those communities support agencies like
they're pretty badly underfunded
especially can compared with healthcare
organizations and also the EHR
incentives that are available to you
know physical health care clinicians
aren't available for mental health and
community agencies so it does seem a
little bit like that would need to come
from the health care and like that kind
of integration of that information would
need to come from the healthcare side
rather than from the community agencies
themselves so like not saying hey
healthcare clinic on the corner or like
behavioral health why don't you collate
all of your different data visits and
send them to us but rather hey we as
OHSU or equivalents will provide a block
grant to do X amount of stuff right it
used to be kind of a bi-directional
partner Rea that maybe that agencies
could work on you know getting consent
and figuring out the privacy part but
they're not gonna have the resources to
actually like set up the technology but
yeah and it I guess in a broader sense
do you have any ideas on how we would do
that or
would work we're such a program to
theoretically exist so you'd have a
question of you know what kind of data
you would want to capture how would you
standardize it how would you because I
mean there will be some overlap between
what the mental health care services and
the local food bank and meals on wheels
and you know medical caller-id will all
be able to get their own you know piece
of the puzzle there will be some overlap
how do you standardize that so that you
can see whether there's agreement with
what they're reporting whether they're
giving different answers but that's
appropriate because of what the
different facets that they're seeing how
do you present that to the clinician in
an easily digestible way we already know
from what these clinicians were
reporting that the community level stuff
is actually harder for them to make
sense of so it would need to be
something that was actually you know
tagged with a patient identifier and
able to say this particular person you
know how those red flags for food
insecurity in this particular person I
saw mental healthcare services or you
know spent a night in a woman's shelter
or whatever else so to make it most
useful it would be the highest level of
complexity as far as privacy and patient
safety about maybe that would be pretty
challenging there's also a component
that a lot of this is people at multiple
levels of community health resources
clinicians ancillary staff trying to
solve a problem that they're not
necessarily in the best position to
solve you know it is a nationwide social
reflection of our priorities that some
people can't afford the right type of
insulin and in the paradigm of looking
at this and how these clinicians are
making these decisions you know they're
not in the position to call someone up
and have that changed or approved but
the decisions that they're making are
necessarily a reflection of you know
national public policy that's saying
we're gonna make this resource not
available certain people mm-hmm yet so
that would that kind of segues nicely
into another question they have which is
like well how does this how would the
information about so
determinants of health translate into
treatment decisions exactly like I could
see okay may be chooses a cheaper
medication but I mean even of the
example they gave and like I totally
agree with the decisions the clinicians
are making in terms of if we put this
person on the mathematically correct
regimen in the context of their lives
they could have major poor outcomes
including like deaths from hypoglycemia
so I think it's a situation of seeing
people willing to do a lot of work in
their own domains and take on other work
that wasn't necessarily what they were
trained to do all with the best
intentions and yet still it is
absolutely an outrage
that we're not just talking about
generic versus brand name medication
we're talking about pharmacodynamic lis
different insulin that is going to have
different effects on your hemoglobin a1c
and cause different sequelae and
potentially poorer management and often
like limiting complications because of
an inability to afford this medication
yeah so it's it almost seems like in
order for social determinants of health
to be actionable it might actually have
to go the other direction right where
the physician is telling you know meals
on wheels hey could you check in on this
person and here's what to look for and
the infrastructure of that is really not
good so even getting physicians to be
aware of what should be incorporated
like what's in the EHR as far as a refer
out to these services is very
rudimentary physicians can feel very
frustrated in terms of they don't see
whether or not that's being effective so
they just feel like they're sending
these referrals out into the ether and
they don't know for sure whether or not
that loop was able to be closed and
unfortunately when you just keep
negatively reinforcing things you get
you get people who will you know try to
incorporate that for a little while see
nothing come of it and give up even if
it was you know a useful or helpful
intervention
yeah I mean I know from working in the
mental health care system that there was
a little support that a lot of times we
would rely on the police if we're
worried about somebody because they can
do a well check right so we can send the
police but that isn't the ideal way to
check on somebody's self is that a
police officer to their door but that's
kind of like the only thing that the
only resource that's available it was an
interesting article
right well that's why I mean this wasn't
an ethics paper but I decided that
eventually became a slide in my next
questions I was like one other question
that feels weird to me this is a whole
slide we need to talk about this I think
it's much easier to make a case for
things like prompting referral to
services and making the clinician aware
of what services there are with respect
of course to be you know who has the
resources in the situation that's
oftentimes the healthcare system but
comparatively speaking but is it then
the responsibility of someone in itg to
run a mate a you know complete itemized
list of all of the mental health
facilities and food banks and so on that
that needs to be in epic so that when a
physician pulls up of you know referral
to ancillary services it says well here
are the local food banks here are what
shelters we have etcetera etc like that
I have an easier time with if that has
shown up in an evaluation as far as an
EHR prompting a change in medical
management based on social determinants
of health that makes me very
uncomfortable so it would certainly be
something that if there was any type of
evidence-based way to say you know if
someone has food insecurity is do we do
we have knowledge of how we should
change their insulin management if there
is a known way to do that that should be
accessible to the clinician who's in
that situation however it's also a
really creepy that we would invest
resources and finding
the best of poor insulin management
options rather than investing resources
and finding out how to get these people
adequate access to food and
refrigeration so you know if there was a
specific you know if you're gonna be on
to our insulin instead of a short and
long acting combination you know can the
provider say okay we're going to use
this treatment plan and start that
cascade you could potentially have some
guided decision-making for well if you
have to kind of step off the beaten path
we have semi beeped out this other path
for you and caught a few other things
but I would have a real hard time with
having EHR prompt provider to say hey
don't try to optimize their Sugar's cuz
that would that would get into like
second-class healthcare
great I'm free and here the resources
that you can use so in help box here are
you know do they have food insecurity
and resources drug integrating it here
are the prescription support primary
it's like it we've got a second one here
[Music]
physicians not asking about diet and
food and things like that but I can
guarantee you that the dietitians aren't
asking about their renal fit well that's
not true we know that but they aren't
asking about all the different medical
comorbidities and there's a reason and
how do we divide that up and what's the
appropriate place just as dr. Hirsch
said what's the appropriate place for
screening for these things what's the
appropriate way to communicate it
between the providers and what's the
appropriate way then to make the medical
decisions and it's it's a complicated
multi-layered problem that's just kind
of even just very minor economic
differences in how the implementation is
set up can have really significant
effects so if you have a dietician at
your clinic so let's say the clinic
workflow is the patient comes in they
have a scheduled appointment with the
diet with a diabetes educator and then
they go to the provider and they have
their medical appointment you know if
the EHR is structured such that whatever
the dietician enters in isn't available
for the clinician at that point you know
that information might not be accessed
and decisions might not be made or the
provider might feel that they have to
ask again or they think oh we'll all
feel weird asking about this again
because I know that my educator just
asked about it but I still can't find it
or it's not clear and and it's you know
a couple of screens of navigator
difference can make the difference
between a well-functioning
multidisciplinary machine and you know
balkanization I mean as a diabetic it's
made a ton of decisions based on the
information that my support team gathers
and when my nurses give me in for me
it's crucial and the dietitians and the
psychologists and all these people who
are playing a role in the team and
they're more and more data saying that
we need that team and then the question
is really how can informatics best
communicate that